[Music]
hey jerk
I got his frozen milkshake please leave
for the day what
milkshakes why I have a girl over she
thinks I live alone and I just come on I
haven't gotten any strange and yeah in
weeks yeah come on I'll pay you back
later maybe sometime Layton
probably not I love my stuff inside take
those straws out of your ears you look
like a white devil
[Music]
whoa whoa what are you doing
operator you shouldn't be here I'm just
trying to call home dad my mom hang up
[Music]
sorry I don't have any bread today guys
hope we could still be friends working
company
[Music]
it's my mom thanks oh yeah right
finally how well I didn't do well on the
real world Garak so I came back here I
was going to hang out in the backyard
but I figured it was close to your
bedroom
so I said on the front porch then I
thought you'd see me so I came up here
yeah good plan yeah
also do we have a ladder all the steps I
saw on the way up just a friggin peered
on the way down no no we don't have a
ladder okay well there you go find one
what you want me to just go up to a
neighbor and say oh hey do you have a
lighter available room yes I'm not gonna
freakin do that why would I do that
just throw an acorn at me that's not
even an acorn tree where'd you get an
acorn from [ __ ] get me a ladder okay
this is Tyler he has a ladder hi hi hey
nice to meet you um I absolutely don't
need a ladder anymore I'm okay though oh
what a relief
[Music]
okay well glad that's over right guys
you can move on with their lives
do you like goat milk ice cream Taylor
no neither you want to go not eat some
inside yes hey um uh you ladder
oh come on you guys aren't even gonna
hook up anyway you're on your period you
don't know that's Yadu man Luke got the
little schedule so you knew how rude
today was you are gonna stay out here
until I'm good and done
[Music]